do i think she's a factor yeah of course
do i think she's the soul factor god no
no if if it is that bad there's something
deeper within will that chooses to stay in
that relationship and that's the
thing that needs to be resolved
what is happening there reject nation greg and
john here today got more big willy things to talk
about so i want to talk about what just happened
i know we're a little bit late to it apologies
got a lot going on in the life as of late and
then uh i want to talk about jada pinkett smith
as well hot topic there the devil woman as the
internet calls her keep her name out of your mouth
all right guys so will smith has been
banned from the oscars for 10 years
here's what's going on the board has decided for
a period of 10 years from april 8th 2022 mr smith
uh shall not be promised we're going to washington
be permitted to attend any academy events or
programs in person or virtually included but
not limited to the academy awards said i'm
past president david rubin and ceo don hudson
of smith's unacceptable and harmful behavior
we also hope this can begin a time of healing and
restoration for all involved and impacted and of
course they said that we want to express our deep
gratitude to mr rock for maintaining his composure
under extraordinary circumstances that he did he
doesn't get enough credit i think we also want to
thank our hosts nominees presenters and winners
for their poise and grace during our telecast
this action we're taking today in response to will
smith's behavior is a step towards a larger goal
of protecting the safety of our performers and
guests and restoring trust in the academy couple
things to note i still feel like in all things
considering it got off pretty easy at least they
didn't take his oscar away you know yeah sure that
and they admitted a little bit of culpability and
how they did or did not handle the situation
and set an example and all that stuff they act
like it's the most horrendous thing ever when they
let the camera roll on him and they kept cutting
back and forth to will to catch his reaction
throughout the night and when it was his time
for his speech oh man they let him go on and
on and on they knew about them ratings and it's
better to ask for forgiveness and they cut to the
academy all standing and giving him an applause
so you know you're just like yeah i'm sure at the
time you were like this is bad but let's milk this
simultaneously let's see how this bad situation
plays out still be good ratings but then we'll
we'll apologize later so something to note will
smith can uh still get nominated though so even
though he's banned he just can't attend
any event and he's not a member anymore
but he can still get nominated meaning he can
still potentially win an oscar which to me is
just insane how nuts would it be if will smith
actually won an oscar in this 10-year time frame
would they allow that to happen can you imagine
if they let will smith win an oscar and just
the kind of weird attention it would draw oh
yeah and then jada goes and accepts the award
the devil woman's on stage i mean it's kind of
crazy because he's got that oscar and while he
should be proud of that oscar it's a little nuts
you know usually when you have something that
level of memorabilia that award that accolade set
up somewhere in your house or given to a family
member every time he sees that i just wonder will
he not be able to think about everything horrible
that has occurred following that event right now
at will smith's house he is literally moving that
thing further and further and further from himself
until it's finally going to wind up in an attic
somewhere and it's just not going to stop guilting
him i mean roman polanski managed to win while he
was uh scared of stepping into the states for all
the reasons he should be scared will smith can
definitely win it'd be exciting to see that happen
i can imagine that also this ban can be lifted
somehow oh sure if he does enough things to
sway the court of public opinion or if he
does something especially uh philanthropic
or gives back and so i mean he's always
on social media doing things so i'm sure he
could demonstrate something that you know the
academy loves a good story and a good underdog i
i don't know if 2032 will be the next time we see
the academy awards let ezra miller take a spot all
right guys moving on here i wanted to talk about
jada pinkett smith i'm not gonna talk uh heavily
specific but there's this clip that's been going
around circulating the web all over again and
before this clip even came out the talks about
miss jada have have already been so predominant
but let's let's play this clip for you guys
really quick you know stan perell is coming to
the table she's going to be at the red table
would you say she has been instrumental
in you and i redefining our relationship
i would say don't just start filming me without
asking me oh my goodness if you confess come help
us again please i'm still dealing with foolishness
don't no no she yeah because she don't just
would you say that she helped us heal the
hurts that we caused between one another
my social media presence is my bread and butter
okay so you can't just use me for social media
and not you know don't just start
wrong i'm standing in my house
don't just start rolling please watch a stare at
the red table because she's helped us a lot can't
you tell okay so uh after that been circulating
a lot you know it's look it's not a good look
for jade because it's not gonna lie for their
relationship whatsoever especially when talking
about bringing like a counselor or therapist
on who's helped them with their relationship
part of me was like i wonder if this is just
the driest form of comedy i've ever seen
i'm just gonna act like a sad child like trying
not to retaliate like the irony of talking about
a woman who's helped her relationship out so
much he's gonna be on a red table and then you're
displaying marital communication problems a
part of me did wonder that it doesn't read
that way it does look like a display of some type
of narcissistic controlling behavior in the form
the skies in the form of sarcasm and then you
know the jada pinkett smith has uh done some
pretty bad things entanglements we call them
entanglements yeah to be safe also there's
been you know times where she's just the way she's
talked about will smith especially in the bedroom
has been quite insulting seems to be a lot of
like demeaning of the man that he is and a lot
of disrespect why i want to talk about this is a
little bit different i find this a whole type of
narrative that's been going around that just seems
like now that will smith has apologized has he
even responded the academy awards he said like a
direct response i accept and respect the academy's
decision with everywhere i see for the past
week it's been so much the target of everything
has been jada pink and smith i am not here to
defend jada pinkett smith i have a however though
i am not here to defend jada pinkett smith i don't
think the solution though moving forward from the
actions that will smith has done is to now make
jada pinkett smith the target yeah i don't agree
with this look the impressions that everyone has
of their relationship i'm right there with you
guys i am i'm totally like the relationship seems
toxic it does seem like there's it's probably a
very emotionally abusive relationship it doesn't
seem healthy this is all the impressions like i
don't know what they're like behind the scenes
could be not as bad could be way worse than more
you know known what we've been privy to so far but
this idea that an order for will smith to rebound
the solution has to cut off jada pinkett smith
maybe maybe for him to heal the ideas to get out
of that relationship maybe i don't think though
that him going up on stage slapping chris rock
yelling at the top of his lungs that's not jada
pinkett smith's fault is it a factor of a lot of
repression that probably played into the situation
maybe but the thing is will smith is a grown ass
man and he's obviously a wise adult as well is he
in a toxic relationship it seems like it sure but
he makes his own choices and he made the choices
that day so i don't think the solution moving
forward is to start putting all the blame trying
to make jada pinkett smith the worst thing in the
world and will smith would totally have all his [
__ ] under control if he wasn't with jada pinkett
smith end of the day you don't know that you can't
transfer that culpability it just doesn't work
that way like she gave him that look and that look
suggests things that everyone has been speculating
supported by other videos like the one you just
saw even if you take that prompt as well she
wanted him to do something he could have chosen
a bunch of other things half of which he still
did anyway yeah so yeah it's not like she controls
literally controls his mind and i feel like that's
a way some people like to portray situations like
this but ultimately yeah it is up to him as to
whether or not he allows that kind of influence to
get in his way and to cause him to make a choice
that he had to have known would be a little bit
muddy in terms of everyone's reception once it
was over with that transference of culpability it
doesn't make sense you could totally fathom that
if he goes to therapy and he's talking he's like
well i've had all this like built up thing with
jada and i feel like less of a man when i'm around
her and i was trying to prove i'm a man and i feel
like she still thinks about tupac or whatever [
__ ] people want to say right like maybe sure that
doesn't matter it was still will smith's choice
it was still him who did it you still got to act
right in public at work and he still chooses if
jade is the devil he still chooses to be with the
devil out of that relationship if it is to the
point where you can't make your own decisions
with a clear mind you can't just say it's all
her you can't just like like uh you know strip
away the sins of will smith by slowly putting it
on the woman in his relationship autonomy he is
still choosing to be in the relationship if it
is as bad as everyone is saying it is sure okay
maybe he won't heal until then he's choosing
that he has more power than her in hollywood
the motivations for some of these speculations
come from in the first yes yeah it's that
discrepancy of status that's got to play a
role in a relationship like this i'll leave
it at this do i think she's a factor yeah of
course do i think she's the soul factor god no
no if if it is that bad there's something
deeper within will that chooses to stay
in that relationship and that's the thing
that needs to be resolved all right guys
well are you team jade or team will yeah where are
you at give your best diss in the comments i think
we can stop talking about this for hopefully 10
more years every time we record one of these we
say this all right well thanks for being here all
right these are [ __ ] weird i know see you guys